blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an
entire non-fiction book in just 15
minutes you can try it for free
and get 25 off a subscription by going
to blinkist.com
pakman let's start today with some very
interesting economic
news despite sort of being held up by
republicans
as the example of everything that is bad
and that should not be done
and that is a disaster of the
progressive left
california's economy is leading the
nation
in growth and in fact is growing almost
as quickly
as the major developing nation of china
if you can believe it and you know this
gloom and doom about lockdowns and
liberal policies and all of this stuff
it really seems not to have held back
the state of california which is number
one
in terms of gdp growth in the united
states
increasing household income investing in
innovation
a whole bunch of other metrics it's
california that's number one
and once again and this has been i mean
go back
all the way to the beginning of
reaganomics and supply side and trickle
down
economic realities seem to increasingly
be the exact
opposite of what right-wingers want you
to believe
in terms of gdp growth california has
grown
22 percent since 2015. the these are
incredible numbers
california has grown on a percentage
basis more than germany
more than japan more than the united
states overall
and almost as much as china china a
developing nation
that is experiencing a rapid economic
growth
expanding middle class etc china has
grown 29
since 2015. california's grown almost
that amount
uh and in the midst of this they're
trying to recall
democratic governor gavin newsom and yet
the state is growing almost
as quickly as china california added 1.3
million people to its non-farm payrolls
since last
april household income increased 164
billion dollars
almost as much as texas florida and
pennsylvania
combined california's budget surplus
yeah it's a surplus you wouldn't know
this from listening to fox news
about california the california surplus
has grown to a record 75 billion
dollars revenue per employee has grown
in california much more quickly than in
the rest of the united states
so there are some really important
takeaways here as we think about
what the sensible economic policy look
like
at the state level first of all the
constant
endless ranting from republicans about
how terrible everything is in california
economically socially culturally and
otherwise
it's just not true is california
expensive absolutely california is
expensive
in the net are taxes higher in
california for someone of average income
than in many other states
that really depends there's this study
that looked at texas versus california
for someone making i think it was like
between 60 and 80 thousand dollars a
year
and if you really account for all of the
expenses
that are levied by the state in
california versus texas and so you look
at
local and property sales taxes fees on
cars and other different things
it ends up being slightly cheaper
to live in california than texas for the
average
person even accounting for the
california state income tax
but the more important takeaway is you
know more recently
the coveted lockdowns as they were
called which not that many
people in california were even really
abiding by the right was saying coveted
lockdowns are destroying california
they didn't destroy the state california
is doing really well california is in
the top
states in terms of portion of its
population vaccinated which is
sort of the logistical and
infrastructure signal about california
so the bottom line is california is
expensive but it's expensive for a
reason and you would think that
republicans would understand this
the people who talk about the free
market the reason that california is
expensive is there's really high demand
and a lot of people
want to live there why do things cost a
lot sometimes things cost a lot because
lots of people want to buy them that's
called
the market now that being said
california
like every state still has many problems
that many metro areas have because it's
in demand
it prices out lots of people including
people who
want to live there but can't afford to
that's a real issue
we can recognize it's expensive because
people want to live there
and that is a market-based thing but at
the same time a lot of people are
getting priced out that's a real issue
we still have huge inequality in both
wealth and income california is no
exception to that
but the lies that you're being fed by
people like tucker carlson and laura
ingram and various of the trumps and
others about the dystopian california
it's not true the undeniable reality is
that california is the envy of the world
in terms of an economy if california
were a country
it would be a significant country
globally and it's just one of 50 states
in the united states
in terms of average standard of living
in terms of innovation
in terms of technology some of the best
places in the world to live are in
california
they aren't in west virginia right i'm
not attacking west virginia
or the people of west virginia but what
i'm saying is there's a massive
infrastructure difference between
california and west virginia
there is a massive education quality
difference there's a massive health care
quality difference
wages are significantly higher and yeah
so all of that together makes california
expensive and it makes west virginia
really cheap
it has to do with politics it has to do
with demand and
it's actually stunning that republicans
get away with trash in california
when it's an obviously incredibly
dynamic
economy that in many ways is the envy of
the world
california would be a globally
successful country
and it's just one of 50 states and in
the midst of this are they going to
recall the governor gavin newsom i don't
know
we will see and we're going to follow it
but the doom and gloom about california
it is just not
backed up by the numbers and uh they
don't
you know it's it's obviously a
transparent political attack there's no
question about that
uh but the degree to which it's
transparently bogus
is only becoming more clear now as we
start to get this data
as we emerge from the pandemic and
they're not going to change their tune
but hopefully you now will know that the
bogus attacks on california are just
that they're simply bogus
hey this is really good news um
democrats
have unveiled a bill proposing
full decriminalization of drug
possession
as well as expunging the records of many
who have already been convicted
uh along those lines and we've been
talking about this
for a very long time we have talked
about the racist origins of the war on
drugs which i will get to
in a moment we've talked about a lot of
other issues related to this
including um the way that police
departments
defend on and for depend on sorry depend
on
enforcing many of these laws in order to
sustain themselves financially
we've talked about private prisons we've
talked about all these different things
and then
there was a question well what are we
going to see from democrats under joe
biden
along these lines and we have now
learned
uh that there is a really comprehensive
bill that has been proposed so let's go
through it newsweek reporting
a bill to end criminal penalties for
drug possession
at the federal level was unveiled by
democrats tuesday yesterday
ahead of the 50th anniversary of
president richard nixon
declaring the war on drugs the drug
policy reform act dpra
would decriminalize personal use
possession of all scheduled drugs
including
marijuana heroin and cocaine and
automatically expunge records and
provide
for re-sentencing for those serving time
for certain drug related arrests now i
know many people will say
david this isn't this isn't perfect we
need legalization instead of
decriminalization and we need to expunge
all
we're talking about major progress if
this were to pass it's already a major
step forward there would still be more
to do but let's actually go
uh let's take these steps it would also
prohibit the denial of employment
immigration status
public benefits voting rights and more
based
upon criminal history for drug
possession
the legislation proposed by uh
representatives corey bush of missouri
and bonnie watson coleman of new jersey
also called for the country to address
substance abuse
with more health-centered approaches
very very important june 17th will mark
50 years since nixon designated drugs as
quote america's public enemy number one
can you imagine
since then drug offenses have become the
leading cause of arrests in the u.s
according to the drug policy alliance
in 2019 more than 1.5 million arrests
were made
due to drug violations under the dpra
authority and criteria for the
classification of substances
would shift from the u.s attorney
general to the secretary of health and
human services this could be a really
big deal in terms of actual rescheduling
it's not just about decriminalization
it's also about rescheduling of drugs
importantly the bill would also direct
the hhs to establish a grant program
supporting initiatives that expand
access to substance abuse
treatment this is really simple guys
this is we should treat
this issue like a public health issue
not a criminal issue and if you go back
to the origins of the war
on drugs and then you look at the
genesis and the catalysts
that led to it you end up understanding
also by the way if you go back even
further to prohibition of alcohol
early in the 20th century the
enforcement of the prohibition of these
drugs
may well lead to more crime than it
prevents i don't think it's exaggerated
to say that and
you would have thought maybe we learned
that during alcohol prohibition in the
united states
there were decades between that and
nixon launching the war on drugs so
maybe it was just too long
the war on drugs also justifies police
departments
asking for a ton of money to fight drugs
when you task police departments
with with fighting you know possession
of drugs
the idea of fighting that criminally is
crazy but when you task them with that
they can justify significantly larger
budgets so
while i am not a defund the police guy
my i'm a reform and fix the police guy
um one of the the really interesting
things about this is that the war on
drugs
justifies higher funding levels
for police and then the need to root out
drug possession is used as a reason to
erode privacy
rights uh public safety across the board
listen uh we've gotta be if we're police
and we need to fight
drug possession as a criminal issue we
should be monitoring phone calls related
to drug deals
we need to be moderate monitoring and
surveilling the internet for drug deals
we need to be able to search houses on
the suspicion of drugs
we shot him because he had drugs or we
suspected that he had drugs or planned
to sell them
how many times have we heard that and
when you go back
to the genesis of this the war on drugs
was created
partially in response to the direction
that civil rights were were going and
had gone in the united states
starting with the civil rights movement
late 50s into the 60s
uh the idea was we need a different way
this was the right saying we need a
different way
to control so-called undesirable
populations and to be able to when we
want to
when we need to deny certain populations
of rights and and this is not an
unfortunate side effect of the drug war
which was otherwise well intentioned
this was the point it's a feature and
not a bug
and in 1994 john ehrlichman
said to harper's journalist dan baum
quote the nixon campaign in 68 and the
white house after that had two enemies
the anti-war
left and black people you understand
what i'm saying we knew we couldn't make
it illegal
to be either against the war or black
but by getting the public to associate
the hippies with marijuana
and blacks with heroin and then
criminalizing both
we could disrupt those communities we
could arrest their leaders we could raid
their homes we could break up their
meetings
vilify them night after night on the
evening news did we know we were lying
about the drugs he asked
of course we did there's no question
about the origins of this
step one and this is j it's really just
step one of many
is we need full decriminalization we
need to expunge
as many of those records as possible
democrats have proposed it proposed it
we'll talk later in the week or early
next about
what is the chance that this really
moves forward and becomes
law uh but let me know your thoughts how
significant do you think this would be i
think it would be
extraordinarily significant if you
disagree or you agree let me know you
can find me on twitter
at deepakman
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly what one of
my favorite apps lets you do it's called
blinkist and what they do is take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down
into text or audio that you can consume
in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
nonfiction book
in just 15 minutes i recently read a
brief history of time
of course by the great stephen hawking
this is a book that i have been aware of
for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic
to check it out on blinkist blinkist has
books on politics philosophy science
they have 27 different
non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month
and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25
percent off a subscription
when you go to blinkist.com slash david
pakman i've put the link
right underneath this video my friends
please don't forget
that the david pakman show is an
independent media program
it's just us we have no big corporate
funders or
overlords or a money tree in the
backyard it's just
us so we depend on you to fund the show
you can help us in achieving that most
simply by getting a membership at
joinedpakman.com
you get access to a daily extra show
just for you just for our members
when you sign up at joinpackman.com
there is more paper trail
where because of newly released emails
we have learned in the last 24 hours
that donald trump and his administration
were pressuring
the department of justice to challenge
the election results of the 2020
election
to try to help trump stay
in power this is it's just every day is
more
the new york times reports that an hour
before president donald trump announced
in december that william barr would step
down as attorney general
the president began pressuring mr barr's
eventual replacement
to have the justice department take up
his false claims
of election fraud trump sent an email
via his assistant jeffrey rosen the
incoming i'm sorry via his assistant
to jeffrey rosen the incoming acting
attorney general
containing documents purporting to show
evidence of election fraud in northern
michigan
the same claims that a judge had thrown
out a week earlier
in a lawsuit filed by one of trump's
personal lawyers
another email from trump to mr rosen
followed two weeks later
again via the president's assistant that
included
a draft of a brief that mr trump wanted
the justice department to file to the
supreme court
it argued among other things that state
officials had used the pandemic to
weaken
election security and pave the way for
widespread
election fraud it simply will
not stop it's another example
of donald trump abusing his power as
president to try to strong-arm people
to steal the election for him it's that
simple and that's the language we should
use about it
trump called the georgia election
officials remember secretary of state
brad raffensberger and
others and said we just need to find
eleven
thousand seven hundred and eighty votes
that's all and then donald trump had
rudy giuliani all over the country
pushing all sorts of bogus nonsense
and now we learned trump was pressuring
the justice department
to help him in doing the exact same it
is really time to start prosecuting
members of the trump administration if
not trump himself there's just no other
option here
and of course if they did it it would be
called out as completely partisan by the
republican party
but if this in some total doesn't
warrant prosecution what does
is quite quite literally
if we don't prosecute over this we're
going back to that nixon idea of if the
president does it it's not illegal
remember how many investigations and
hearings they had
about benghazi that they successfully
were able to hold
in order to try to hurt hillary clinton
politically and now look at what's going
on
now some of you might say this is just
too much even for trump supporters
finally it's just everything's coming up
the trump supporters are finally
going to be convinced to abandon donald
trump because of this or because of the
next thing
no way no they will say the report is
fake news
or they will say well no trump had to do
it because it was biden who stole the
election from him so
trump had to go to the justice
department
and to lobby the supreme court to give
him the election because biden's the one
who stole it and guys
these are the people who when the power
went out in texas
because of that isolationist right-wing
decision
to totally separate the texas power grid
from the rest of the country
these are the right wingers who said the
the reason the power went out is wind
power it's with
frozen windmills that's the explanation
for them the ends justify the means
and if they simply believe that donald
trump had to do it
to stop joe biden from stealing the
election and stop joe biden's socialism
they don't care they don't care what
trump
may have done or may have tried to do to
stay in power so
we it's been five years guys where we
say oh this this
this they they won't tolerate now
they're going to nope they just look the
other way or they excuse it now one
other thing
there are people saying don't prosecute
trump because of fears of violence
if you prosecute trump it's going to
trigger
even more violence on the streets that
may be true
but it can't be the reason that this is
not pursued
it just can't be trump formed a
coalition of these
ignorant and sometimes violent people he
weaponized their ignorance and
gullibility into the trump riots and
more
and then he weaponized their gullibility
into raising tens of millions of dollars
supposedly to fight this fraud and to
fight that fraud and to recount this and
that
and then now we're going to say listen
they may become even more violent if we
do what we need to do which is to
actually prosecute this
that can't happen it simply cannot be
that that's the reason
why they're all allowed to get away with
it and by the way
won't they be emboldened in some sense
if trump and everybody around trump
does end up skating in the sense that
they will have done
all of this huge list of things won't
have succeeded at getting trump back in
power but they will have done it all
this attempt that attempt these lies
those bogus lawsuits
the january six riots on and on and on
and no consequences
that will embolden them for the next
time and whether the next time is august
or 2022 or 2024 we don't yet know but
we can't say now they're gonna get
violent if we prosecute so we can't do
it that
that's not how the united states of
america works
okay i have received dozens
of emails and tweets and comments asking
me to weigh in about what's currently
happening with the online left
as many of you know i really don't watch
much online political media i limit
myself to the stuff i read
to be ready to do the show and then i
have other interests and limited time
each day but
i am sort of aware of a bunch of the
different things that have been going on
with the online left and i want to talk
about it a little bit because i do think
that it's actually
there's a lot to say here now as i
understand it there's a few different
controversies
happening right now i am very much aware
of young turks host jenk yuger and also
young turks host anna casparian
embroiled in again if i understand it
correctly it's a couple of different
controversies
one is specifically related to another
host named jimmy dore
and sexual harassment or harassment as
some like to say
and then another kind of more general uh
controversy is
between jenk and the young turks and a
sort of contingent of the authoritarian
revolutionary left that has a presence
online people like
glenn greenwald and others i'm not
exactly sure who else is part of this
and so
a few things are going on uh there and
then on the other hand it seems as
though
there was kind of a shake-up at the
hills rising and there are new hosts
there
and that seems to be going pretty poorly
from the one one thing i read about it
and the question i've basically been
getting from people in the audience
is whether the online left is tearing
itself apart
in a way that is counterproductive to
the progressive movement
and whether the left has become overrun
with uh with with grifters
so let's take these questions one at a
time and and i want to say i was
actually just interviewed for a podcast
uh by cliff schechter and john aravosis
where we talk quite a bit about this and
we're going to publish this over the
weekend and um
we talk a lot about this issue if the
topic interests you
there's you know probably 20 minutes of
this stuff in that episode which we'll
publish to our youtube channel
so first of all the fact that there are
different views on the quote left
is not bad it's not a source for concern
and it's always been my perspective that
diversity of opinion
is fine and good and should be applauded
and welcomed
what has been a concern for me has been
the increased gatekeeping
that i've seen some on the left engage
in which includes call outs about who
really is or isn't on the left i've
received many of those
as well as kind of shaming people for
views and generally unproductive insults
when somebody doesn't
line up 100 with your political
perspective generally speaking
diversity of opinion is good it's not a
problem in and of itself
what is a problem is when people start
to focus merely on calling out others
either for personal reasons or for
clicks or for money or to gatekeep
or to virtue signal or for whatever
reason they do it so i'm gonna give you
an example
when jimmy dore has attacked me he did
on twitter during the election
period last year i've mentioned my views
differ from jimmy doors
but i don't base my show and my identity
around calling out
people like jimmy dore with whom i have
differences of opinion first of all it
just seems so boring
secondly it's so childish third what
would i even get from doing that
it would probably be profitable and i've
jokingly talked with others about who
should i start a fake beef with
because it gets attention but it's just
not me it's not productive in any in any
real sense
now the issue of grifters is a
complicated one
and when i say grifter what i mean is
someone
is creating a persona and covering
stories
or taking positions or covering stories
in a way that doesn't represent who they
really are
either because they've decided i can
concoct this persona and appeal to a
certain audience
or it's going to be profitable in some
way i might get paid speaking gigs or
whatever the case may be now here's what
i can say about that
i'm going to give you a list of people
that i know are not
grifters and what i mean by that is
whether we agree or disagree
on any particular issue what you see
them say
publicly lines up completely with what
they say privately they are not playing
characters
they're not calculating their positions
for how it's going to be perceived by
their audiences or
for profitability and the reason i'm
able to give you this list
is because i know both these people's uh
public
work as well as knowing them privately
as individuals
and in no particular order here are
people that are not grifters
uh jenkin anna from the young turks i've
known them both for a long time
if you talk to them privately what they
say is exactly what they say on their
show
we don't have to agree about everything
surely i'd have differences with them
about for example the
israeli-palestinian conflict but
they are totally sincere in what they
say and what they believe would be best
for the world
i am totally sincere in what i say there
is no grift or calculation there
great okay sam cedar from the majority
report i've been to what must be at this
point 15 or 20 conferences with sam over
the years where we spend hours together
every political conversation i've had
with sam and that i've heard
and overheard sam have with other folks
including people from the revolutionary
left etc
the public sam and the private sam is
exactly the same person no grift
kyle kalinski i've hung out with kyle um
and i've talked to kyle a ton over the
years the kyle you see on his
youtube channel as far as i know and
again i don't watch a lot of this stuff
online
it's the same kyle that i know privately
farron cousins from ring of fire is the
same
guy politically privately as he is
publicly
um no mickey from the nomicy show i've
known her for probably a decade
private nomicky and public nomakey are
the same person
this is not someone who i guess we
traditionally consider to be on the left
and this
i don't know how my audience will react
to this joe rogan
whatever your problems are with the
things
rogan says and i recently did a video
where i said i disagree with what joe is
saying about
vaccination i think he's mistaken uh
there is no
act there i can tell you rogan five
minutes before
the show starts and an hour after and on
the show it's the it's the real rogan
okay now anybody outside of this list
some of them are grifters but many of
them i just don't know privately so i
can't really say i don't know well
enough to say
their public persona is different than
the person they are in private either
for profit or not
some i don't want to name names because
then i'm just engaging in the same stuff
but there are plenty of grifters
so then the question is is the grifting
going to tear the left apart but
probably not
um some people will make money and are
making money
um with the grifting with the calculated
fake personas
there are others who will then make
money from attacking the grifters
and on and on it's not really my thing
i don't think it's particularly good for
the progressive movement
to have people with retrograde
ideologies
passing themselves as being on the left
you know if you are an authoritarian
or a faux populist or you defend or
sympathize the authoritarians or the
faux populists and the dictators and the
strong men
i would question whether you're really
on the left
it's not a left i recognize but i don't
know that it's really going to
tear the left apart a lot of these
movements seem
way bigger if you look at twitter and
reddit and youtube
than they really are but it's going to
continue being profitable so it's going
to continue
that's basically my take and a lot of it
is very boring
a lot of it is extraordinarily childish
and
the unfortunate reality is that to some
degree
we're all slightly narcissistic and what
i mean by that is
anybody who i mean okay if you're
neurodivergent then there
this this may not apply okay but for for
people who are
you know not autistic and you decide i'm
gonna have a show where i give my
opinion
there's some degree of narcissism there
there has to be because somewhere you
believe that
your opinion may be as opposed to
or different than millions and millions
and millions of people who
it never occurs to do a show your
opinion
is of some value entertainment or it's
something that other people would want
to listen to so
you're going to have a lot of
interesting and different personalities
in this space but within that there's a
huge huge spectrum
and by its nature you're going to get
this
this stuff within the space and i think
that
there are aspects of it that aren't good
for the progressive movement
but i don't think it's ultimately going
to be destructive
in in the way that some believe it's
going to be because much of the survival
of this very space the online left
depends on conflict and depends on
controversy and so
the the idea that it will become a
distraction from policy sure
but it's not going to destroy the space
overall we'll have more
of this on our instagram you can follow
us on instagram at davidpakmanshow
and i'd love to hear your thoughts as
well
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a
member which gives you access to the
daily bonus show
the regular show with no commercials you
also get access to our entire archive
of every episode dating back a really
long time
and plenty of other awesome membership
perks go to joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21
for a huge discount join pacman.com
it's great to welcome to the program
today dr ashish jah who is a physician
brown university professor and a
world-renowned expert on pandemic
preparedness and response
uh it's so great to have you on i i have
so many questions and and we'll just
jump right in
first things first um lots of folks
who were very confident in following cdc
guidelines for 95 percent of this
pandemic
um were taking a little bit of back at
what seemed like a very rapid uh
advancement from the cdc in terms of
mask wearing and what's safe
particularly for vaccinated people
what what's your general sense of the
balance that the cdc struck between what
makes sense medically and also trying to
do things to encourage more people to
want to get vaccinated
yeah so first of all david thanks for
having me here i'm excited to be on
and you know the cdc has a couple of
different jobs right on one hand
they want to explain to people what the
science is they want to explain to
people what the evidence is
so you have to go read all the
scientific papers yourself you can if
you want but you don't have to the cdc
will give you that summary
and then they also have a job of giving
advice to policymakers about how to
manage that science
and what the cdc did was they came out
and said look the science
is pretty clear if you've been fully
vaccinated you're good to go you do not
need to be wearing a mask in most
instances
and you're really you're fine the
problem
is that implementing that policy is hard
for governors because
they don't know who's vaccinated who's
not and i think there was
maybe a little more attention could have
been paid to thinking through well how
is this going to get implemented
but you know the people who defend the
cdc's decision basically say
mask mandates were kind of on their way
out anyway a lot of states had already
lifted them
and so what the cdc was really doing was
just explaining to people what they
already knew which was that
all the mask wearing all the mask
mandates they're kind of on their way
out
the one thing that i hear from lots of
parents which
they just don't seem to have an answer
for it and i don't either is
the numbers are going down we're seeing
lower numbers
in many states almost down to
statistical baseline of risk for being
out in the world et cetera but nobody
under 12 has been vaccinated
and so how does this all compute
and how are we to to think about that
part
yeah no it's a really good question i
have a
you know so i have three kids two of
them are above the age of 12 they're
14 and 16 and one of them is nine who
obviously has not gotten vaccinated so i
think about this a lot from my own
family
and here is how i would think about this
uh and this is what i've recommended to
people
first if you want to protect kids under
12 the single best thing you can do
is make sure everybody around them is
vaccinated their parents their
older siblings that becomes critical
right that sort of
creates a ring of protection against
those kids second you want to live in a
community with relatively high
vaccination rates
and what that will do is make sure
infection numbers are really low
and then for some high risk things maybe
you want to pay a little extra attention
so
when i think about it you know we have
not done indoor dining with my
nine-year-old
we probably could infection numbers
where i live are really really low
but i've done indoor dining by myself uh
because i'm fully vaccinated
and so what i have recommended is watch
the infection numbers as they get lower
and lower you can do more and more
indoors without mass for kids
but maybe for some indoor things it's
reasonable to still have the kids mask
up
if you're going to be in a crowded
indoor space let's say you're in a
community where not everybody or not a
lot of people are vaccinated
that's where you want to be careful but
other than that right now i think we're
pretty
in pretty good shape even for younger
kids who have not gotten vaccinated
should there be special guidelines for
folks who
have been vaccinated but have either
some particular medical condition or
are immunocompromised or and and if so
for now
at what point can that be eased off of
yeah it's a very good question um you
know so what's interesting about this
and i get
asked about this a lot from patients and
i talk about this a lot with my
colleagues
immunocompromises a broad group of
people
who have some amount of immunodeficiency
some of those people
their vaccine works just great they're
essentially
it works as well as it does for anybody
else some of those other people
the vaccine barely works at all and so
first and foremost you've got to have a
talk with your doctor about the kind of
immune compromised state you have
because it really does vary a lot second
for the people who are
unfortunately in that small group for
whom the vaccine essentially doesn't
work at all
there's studies going on of maybe a
third or a fourth dose of the vaccine
could get them more protection
but unfortunately they need to act like
they're unvaccinated because they are or
their
immune system is acting that way and so
they need to continue to mask up
and if you're if you live with somebody
with one of those more severe forms of
immune compromises you have to be very
careful
certainly everybody around them should
be fully vaccinated
one of the reasons why we've got to get
to very very high levels of vaccination
is there a small proportion of people in
our country who are vulnerable for whom
vaccines won't work
we've got to do a better job protecting
them when we
talk about some of the variants
including the delta variant
maybe first to make sure i'm
understanding the math correctly
if if we read for example that a
particular variant is 60
more transmissible would it be correct
to understand that that means that
given a particular scenario call it
eight minutes
indoors unvaccinated right if normally
there would be a one percent
transmission risk
for it to be 60 more transmissible does
that mean that that becomes a 1.6
transmission risk yeah exactly
exactly that it's 60 relative so you
don't go from 1 to 61
thank goodness of course uh but right if
you let's say you were at 10
now you're at 16 uh it's that
it's at 60 relative risk but may not
sound like a lot
but it actually when you apply it across
the whole population it's
massive and you can see it in a place
like the united kingdom
which by the way has higher vaccination
rates than we do still i mean but we're
about the same but they're a little
higher
you know they have seen because of the
delta variant and the contagiousness
they have seen a three to four-fold
increase in total number of infections
across the country
despite high vaccinations because this
ver this virus this variant
is so much more contagious so for the
average person who's vaccinated would
learning about the increasing prevalence
of that variant
change what one considers to be safe
like what i mean is
if you're vaccinated and you see the
case numbers and you're saying i'm gonna
do a trip in two weeks
we now learn about the fact that this
variant is out there
should the average person change their
activity as a result of that
if you're fully vaccinated no if you're
fully vaccinated the good news is
that the vaccines we have hold up very
very well against the delta variant
so if you're let's say you're planning a
trip with four of your friends and
they're all fully vaccinated
do your trip don't worry about the delta
variant the delta variant
you know it poses a marginal problem for
people who are fully vaccinated not much
of one you just tend to get a little bit
more breakthrough infections but not
people don't get sick because they're
fully vaccinated
delta variant is a huge problem for
people who are not vaccinated
those people are at super much much
higher risk without
you know with the delta variant without
but if you're fully vaccinated i
wouldn't worry
can you talk a little bit about
particularly in the last three weeks
the uh hypotheses and discussions about
the origins of this
virus have gone i i don't want to say
that it's gone mainstream but there's
been significantly more discussion
including in places where we were not
originally seeing it
my understanding of the spectrum of what
is possible would be on the one hand
this had nothing to do with any lab even
as a pit stop
all the way to this was designed as a
bio weapon and deliberately
released i think it's important no
matter what we explore
to not claim something to be likely
until we have reason to believe that
it's likely but what do you make of the
change in that discussion over the last
few weeks
and sort of the state of that question
yeah so let's talk about the science and
where we are first on the science and
then i will talk about the discussion
yeah so you actually really laid out the
spectrum
well i could have just been a a standard
animal to human
species jump very common it's how we
get ebola it's how we got zika this is
pretty much the most common way
that we get novel infections all the way
to it was a bio weapon designed
uh to cause a global epidemic um
you know but that so basically the way i
look at it bioweapon design
incredibly unlikely a bit more likely
is it was it was in a lab now it could
have been a naturally occurring virus
people were studying in the lab and
there was an accidental leak
that is more likely or it wasn't
deliberately designed as a bio weapon
but they were working on gain of
function
and they caused a virus to become more
lethal and then it leaked
you know a little bit less likely but
still on the possibility range
most likely just based on kind of
experience historical that
there was an animal to human jump that
there's a species of animals probably
bats maybe there's a different
intermediary and and humans got infected
the reason i say that's most likely
because again that's how it usually
happens
but here's the bottom line i don't know
the answer and i would argue that
probably no one else does either i mean
if it was a lab leak maybe a small
number of people do
but i certainly don't no one else in the
united states does so what do we need to
do and first of all why is it important
it is important we want to know where
this virus came from we want to
understand it
not just because it helps us unmanage
this one but prevent future ones
but the other part is we have got to
stop politicizing this like
my god at this point we have managed to
take this thing that's a very
complicated and important scientific
question
and people are talking about it as
though like if you're a democrat you
believe one thing in a republican you
believe another
i just don't know the right answer we
need to investigate it we need to push
china to give us
more cooperation we need to have the u.s
intelligence and other
intelligence agencies investigated we
really do need to get to the bottom
bottom of this again if i were a betting
person i'd say probably came from an
animal but we're not we're not making
bets here
we should actually sort it out is it um
uh
the is it concerning or is it in any way
relevant
or something we should be thinking about
that it's not clear
who the first human to be infected was
or is that just
not particularly surprising if indeed
the first human or humans were in a
country of 1.3 billion people
yeah i think it's important to try to
figure out how far back
does this go so there's some recent data
now that's coming out
that suggests that the first cases in
the united states may have been in late
december
and in people who were not traveling
that means that they got it they were
infected by somebody who had traveled
here
maybe in early december starts pushing
the timeline back
you know we probably won't find what
people talk about as kind of patient
zero the first person infected
yeah i doubt we'll find that we might
but i doubt it
but understanding when the virus got
going when were the first group of
people infected
who were the first group were they
people in a lab were they people working
who stopped at that market i think that
will be important part of the tracing
here this has been such a
horrible pandemic we have got to get to
the best of our ability
to the origin not just where it came
from but who are the first people
infected
last thing i wanted to ask about um
certainly you like many of us have been
seeing that there is a very
significant correlation right now
between political views and and
vaccination rates
um red and blue states and also within
those states individuals who identify
politically
one way versus the other are these rates
now or could they be different enough
that the future of this virus becomes
essentially it a partisan virus where
there is one political group that is
disproportionately dying from this in
the united states
he has a good question so i actually see
it a little bit differently and let me
kind of make the case for why
okay when i look at the data i mean
there's no doubt about it if you just
look red states versus blue states it
looks like blue states are doing great
on vaccinations red states are not but
there's other things about red states
versus blue states so for instance
uh public health infrastructure public
health infrastructure is much better in
a lot of these quote unquote blue states
and that's what's allowing vaccines to
get out to people i still find in a lot
of
quote unquote red states there are a lot
of people who want to be vaccinated
but they're far away from vaccine sites
it's not easy for them to get time off
there are enough barriers that it's
still preventing people so
i hope that the partisan divide gets
better
i and part of it is i can look at states
like south dakota which is a
very red state and 60 to 63
of adults have gotten vaccinated almost
at the same level as the national number
and i think oh yeah
like there are plenty of people on both
sides of political aisle who have gotten
vaccinated
um i don't i think if this were to
become a partisan virus i think if it
were to become something
that infected one political group more
than i think that'd be very bad for our
country
it would really sap our desire to have
kind of a unified response
it would make this just a bad thing the
virus certainly doesn't care about the
politics we've got to do everything we
can
to de-politicize the virus not look at
it as a
red versus blue thing but as a human
versus virus thing
and everybody get on the team human and
figure out how to defeat the virus
without uh with without question yeah
we've been speaking with dr
ashish jah who is a physician and brown
university
professor i so appreciate your time
today hey it was my pleasure thanks for
having me on
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon
go to patreon.com david pakman show
where you can get access to behind the
scenes videos
the daily bonus show the commercial free
daily show
as well as special discounts on merch
including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts
you can support the show for as little
as
two dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com
davidpakmanshow alright this is pretty
interesting a former president donald
trump has a new spokesperson
his spokesperson had been that guy jason
miller but miller stepped down
last week and the new spokesperson is a
woman named liz harrington
liz harrington used to be the
spokeswoman for the republican national
committee she's a real bomb thrower and
harrington's big qualification appears
to be that
she supported a whole bunch of lies
about the 2020 election which trump
liked including the lie that
president biden strong performance in
some democratic counties clearly was a
sign that there must have been some kind
of election
fraud and one of the things that we've
been talking about is why might it be
that even now so many republican elected
officials are either standing by
trump or at least not criticizing donald
trump and it seems pretty clear that
the reason is they see him probably
rightly so
as still wielding lots of power even for
their own possible reelections
in 2022 and they don't want to burn a
bridge until they know they're not going
to need to drive over that bridge any
time soon
so donald trump announces this new total
suck-up brown-nosing
a spokeswoman says that harrington is a
fighter
apparently a fighter for completely
bogus conspiracy theories
and harrington is just off to a blazing
start she appeared on i don't even know
what this is
the real america's voice show
just the truth the truth is that the
show is all lies
and in this clip harrington says that
the january 6th
trump riots were a peaceful protest
among many other lies you'll notice also
that the interviewer
is former i guess it's former trump
lawyer or was she trump's lawyer you
know but we never really know
uh sometimes she was sometimes she
wasn't jenna ellis
she's the one that caught covid while
traveling around the country with rudy
giuliani
pushing completely bogus voter fraud
stuff so let's jump right in this is
trump's
new spokeswoman liz harrington here we
go oh absolutely and again we've seen it
there's such a void
i mean you're you're not going to get it
from the biden regime because everyone
knows he's not actually running things
so there's two things here that are
important
the biden regime is another phrase that
they've started using and this is of
course part of their idea that they want
to push that
the biden administration is some kind of
dictatorial
communist government controls everything
sort of administration so biden regime
is one thing we're hearing from them the
second piece is
the idea that biden isn't really running
the show
and the idea so this is actually twofold
there's a
like the big story and then the little
one the big story is
it's the biden dementia story that it's
really kamala harris or someone else
who's
running the administration but this
happens to fit
perfectly with anti-semitic stuff for
republicans as well
and what i mean by that is the concept
of a behind-the-scenes jewish puppeteer
pulling the strings of american
government that's a classic anti-semitic
trope
and so there's also sort of some
symbolism there as to why that's so
appealing to many on the right it's not
overtly anti-semitic although there were
you know these uh things floating around
about you know a lot of jews here
ron clayne and janet yellen and i don't
know who at blinken i don't remember who
else
so it's it's all kind of part of this
package and it doesn't always have to be
overtly signaling
jews but the idea of like the real
people pulling the strings behind the
scenes
it's implicitly part of an anti-semitic
trope all right let's continue
and it's so important at this time in
our country i mean
we have no equal justice under the law
right now at the federal level
that's completely untrue other than if
you mean
that we have a two-tiered justice system
where the rich and the powerful
are in a different sort of class of
their own what she means is certainly
not true
i mean just look at what they're doing
with the justice department you know
they didn't look into
any of these irregularities oh no that's
not the federal government's role right
it's literally not it's literally not
the role and
these are the very same people who
constantly insist
elections are run at the state level
which is why we should be allowed
to restrict voting however we want we
shouldn't have the federal government
involved in any way in how elections
take place no voting rights act no
nothing until all of a sudden they say
well we have
six six or seven but you know bogus
election
fraud claims why isn't the federal
government now getting involved
the state's role and then all of a
sudden here comes a forensic audit
authorized forensic got it by the way
come on so the constitution and here
comes
the corrupt justice department i mean
and we're talking about peaceful protest
it was not a peaceful protest if if
anything was not a peaceful protest
it was the january 6 riots which now has
about 400
criminal defendants who had january 6
they opened the doors of the capitol
which is supposed to be i mean
we've both been there it's not an easy
building to get into
well that is of course not what happened
first of all
uh protesters physically breached the
door
and secondly for their own safety and to
avoid
tramplings officers had no choice but to
get the hell out of the way so
every detail has been being misstated
here you know there's that many people
they open the doors and people walk
through
obviously we're not condoning breaking
property or
violence oh you're not some people just
got just walks
in and now they're being kept and for
misdemeanors
in some political jail and what is
happening here what
what about the people that burn down st
john's church st john's church by the
way uh
was not burned down and that is yet
another one of the distortions and lies
here so in all seriousness they
are going to continue trying to rewrite
the story
of what happened on january 6th we can't
let them do it
st john's wasn't burned down it was not
a peaceful protest
um and uh consider how far things have
gone
that donald trump's new spokeswoman who
is the former republican national
committee spokeswoman
sounds more like q anon than she sounds
like mitt romney you know just a kind of
milk toast republican that we've come to
know
uh more more of this uh and by the way
they continue these conflicting
narratives of nothing really
happened on january 6th but if it did
it wasn't trumpists it was people
pretending to be trumpist that also is a
narrative that continues so
for now as you see you know former rnc
spokeswoman is now trump's spokeswoman
the republican party seems at least for
now completely fine
staying completely associated with
donald trump
let's do a quick uh look through a
recent
press conference that republican
congresswoman marjorie taylor-green gave
as we talked about earlier in the week
she now has apologized and said you know
when i compared stuff to the holocaust
that was wrong there's nothing like the
holocaust she learned at age 47 that the
holocaust is really bad
and some people thought hey you know
what she seems sincere maybe things are
going in the right direction with
marjorie taylor green
very much not at all here she is
yesterday being asked have you been
vaccinated and check out what she says
i stand with the americans that want
their privacy
and hipaa gives us gives us rights to
privacy
with our medical information and so i
appreciate you asking
but that is my right to keep my medical
information private
so understand that hipaa has nothing to
do
with journalists asking her questions
this is being used
frequently by the right and sometimes
these talking points just they get a
they get ahead of steam it's like a
runaway train hipaa
hipaa sean hannity said the same thing
on his show a few weeks ago he said
you know i was going to talk about my
vaccination decision
but all these people now are asking me
have you been vaccinated and hipaa
medical privacy
hipaa relates to medical providers and
your information
and the safe keeping of it doctors can't
say whether you are
or aren't a patient unless you've
authorized them to do it your medical
records have to be kept safe and private
etc
a journalist saying have you been
vaccinated to a politician
particularly one who's a public figure
has nothing
to do with hipaa and this was not the
only wacky thing that happened here
the republican attacks on dr fauci
continued
here is marjorie taylor green talking
about that the fire fouchy act will
bring dr
fauci's by the way the fire fouchy act
this this is a delusional person salary
down to zero
and also will require the senate to
confirm
someone to fill his position right you
see dr
fauci was not elected by the american
people yes as he was not
which is not uncommon for lots of people
in positions of medical significance
chosen to guide our economy he was not
and he
literally says when asked i am not an
economic person
we actually have exa it's funny she says
he was not chosen to guide our economy
there have been times where dr fauci has
been asked questions during hearings
about
how would you evaluate this guideline
with its economic
impact and dr fauci straight up says i'm
not an economics guy i just make medical
recommendations that's for economists or
politicians or for whoever else to
actually talk about and decide
not chosen to rule over
parents and their children's education
and then that's more of this stuff about
fauci is uh the democrats and fauci and
people who have
medical opinions are uh in some way
dictatorial overlords over the general
public which is funny because
30 or 40 percent of the country didn't
do a damn thing of all the different
things that were recommended by medical
professionals so very weak
overlordship is what it sounds like and
then lastly marjorie taylor green also
asked about her continued use of the
term china virus and she said it's not
uh it has nothing to do with race you
know you call it the china virus you
suggest
that it's a bio weapon there's no
evidence of any of that
and we're also in the middle of a spate
of attacks against
asian americans aren't you just feeding
that uh
pretty easily absolutely not absolutely
not and you're not going to turn this
into something else this is a virus that
killed all kinds of people
it had nothing has nothing to do with
anyone's race or ethnicity it has
nothing to do with any of that so
well but okay but nationality at minimum
right i mean still calling it the china
virus
not at all okay so there she's just
dismissing that completely out of hand
so this this is a really gross woman
guys
uh as as if you couldn't tell of this
completely disgusting person
and whether she was really serious in
her apology about the holocaust stuff
i don't know uh but certainly not
someone who seems to be on the path to
making any more sense recently that's
for sure
we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 david p
here is a military veteran who says uh
i'm anti-american take a listen
hi david hey david this is bill from
fayetteville uh
retired army officer david i just want
to know why uh you seem to be so
anti-american
so uh when you see what biden has done
uh well his corrupt son the amount of
money the hunter
uh so you said what has biden done what
what biden has done but now you're
talking about hunter i'm family has done
james biden
hunter biden why you don't want to
discuss that so notice that i
that is something we've discussed and he
says you you won't talk about what
biden has done but then hasn't listed
anything biden's done
uh the corruption of uncle joe uh uh you
know uh and ten percent goes to the big
man
tony babilinski and all that stuff yeah
we've covered all of that stuff
and you know you got you you do you like
to have your own country trashed by
omar and and to lead i i have never
spoke out and said that
my uh political uh heroes and guiding
north star
are ilhan omar and rashida talib so it
sounds like it's someone who's never
watched this show maybe and the radical
left are you a solinsky uh
aficionado there uh david you know uh
i wonder david pakman it sounds like to
me like you might be from jewish
uh uh forebears that might have been a
good god-fearing jews you see where
uh nadler has to remove the word god
from the oath
and there it is my friends and there it
is you don't have to go
too far until that comes up
um i present it with no further comment
we've got a great bonus show for you
today
don't miss it become a member at
joinpacman.com to get
instant access i will see you then
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
non-fiction book in just 15 minutes
you can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription
by going to blinkist.com david pakman